oh [ __ ] yeah down right now I'm gonna
jump down there I'm gonna clear us a
path what about me you stay here this is
so stupid we'd have more of a [ __ ]
chance if you let me help I am nice not
you seem to know your way around a gun
you reckon you can handle that well I
sort of shot a rifle before but it was
that rats rats with bb's dadgad well
it's the same basic concept lift it up
all right now you can lean right into
that stock is it he's gonna kick a hell
of a lot more than any baby rifle mmm go
and pull the bolt back grab it right
there shut up pop Akio as soon as you
fire you're gonna want to get another
round in there quick listen to me I
getting in trouble down there you make
every shot count yeah okay got I got
this yo la you're my girl all right you
like Al Haig I'll bet yes and just so
we're clear about back there it was
either him or me okay you're welcome all
right let's do this [ __ ] no it's deal
I'm gonna make sure you get away right I
would have done
Oh leap oh [ __ ] let's go check the
street thank you there we go hey call me
that gun cases are because I'm always
moving over here Cat Cat Cat Cat Edgar
oh [ __ ] I'm pressing the wrong [ __ ] in
the [ __ ] this change that's up okay
who's laughs here's what I know there's
[ __ ] out here
I keep doing that I got him right oh
yeah you see that shit's not one his
head yeah stomp on there's another one
here isn't there yeah oh [ __ ] [ __ ] suck
my dad saw my deck suck my dick yeah
suck it you're gonna suck it
oh come on down now that was not bad at
all it was nice to be have them
extracted I got this one so don't rank
the whole time take credit and take
credit how'd I do got got ya I got ya I
got kit all right elmet about something
a little more your size it's for
emergencies only okay
Arjun say is like every [ __ ] day that
every rooms an emergency up [ __ ] sorry
okay are we gonna be able to navigate a
zone you do how to switch it off I do
you just you got a respected this is not
good great ok let me realign and good
huh you're like a shot it out hey I'm
over shani maybe checking these
apartment complexes for mo no I'll take
that thank ya uh hello sir like to read
it right there don't need the fireflies
um like I oughta punch of crack [ __ ]
they people hanging ceiling with the
room I don't need that now I'd like to
get myself saying okay I don't need to
be staying at that and I was saying fall
oh I can make here like in a lot of
these bad boys coming yet don't mind it
I tell you know what I'm saying oh I
really walking for these check one
where's the bridge dead there's a bridge
here with a lot of [ __ ] in there
okay oh can I get some moves meted
[ __ ] my is that the Scots tag let me
see it look like like up close where
these colors didn't like [ __ ] me ah
there kid very well elephants I like
though they're cute and I love them okay
gets grown in here now and at the Cape
I'll guess I'll tap this in advance tap
tap tap yep I knew it he's always
thought about the right support guys do
your thing really stupid chain is stuck
hold on there good thank a good thinking
it's good thinking oh that but I could
use that so um okay dad I take this help
me open this yeah hey [ __ ] sucks at
this one all right
I sure what's here about 20 take this
thank you ooh workbench yeah okay I
don't know why he needs like a favor can
I think any jadi I cannae inch ah I
really use the bow hmm gasps us to be
good I guess yeah shut out there we go
okay so I got there Oh it makes it quick
that's nice good god I like this um can
I make anything yes i can look another
one of these fine boys it's only five
little setback when I got it [ __ ] [ __ ]
get down get your [ __ ] get down will
[ __ ] us at not dealt a while ah I says
it's doubly basil whatever man yeah no
food old pair of shoes
let's go yeah they kill nothing about
that
oh my god oh man ain't nothing we go
down I know it's just follow me let's
just give this bridge can cause I can
you know let's just get to that bridge
dry sound like a badass
okay listen mode that says activate our
mouths shut da [ __ ] did they wipe out
the entire crew I got you oh [ __ ] oh
shut suck my dick suck my turn hmmm
let's just be cool man memory knee said
Leslie cool well let me tell you
something [ __ ] the cool kids were the
DEP shits in a high school so I ain't
gonna be cool [ __ ] I gotta make a
[ __ ] hell thing now if I get no I
need to make a healthy organic [ __ ]
Nathan here now I'll ya nothin is that
you say that's a not a dog wolf or two
okay yeah ouch what the [ __ ] i seriously
just hurt myself for that I think this
broad hi guys I'm the donna wolfe i'm at
dawn woof am I supposed to be [ __ ]
doin I think nothing out here
can I go that far no
yeah I see stay low chef
oh this is all this [ __ ] on it oh [ __ ]
tell this [ __ ] ouch [ __ ] Ellie I'm a
shot you wait it's not Ellie's it shut
hmm mouth shut jetta million shot
blocking shot I need to crap one of
these guys but I can't right now so nice
looking at
where's where are they
i am not done Oh
alright that [ __ ]
okay what Oh Randy comic book thing head
get get and that was very hastily done I
gotta say but let me go where that guy
was up there and get a [ __ ] out of out
of this so I'm ways well there's a
[ __ ] bow and arrow time I'm sure a
lot of people were probably infuriated
by the way I handle that and you know
there's not gonna but it is this I look
back now I just watch them opt out
captain mast Rosenstein brand them alive
yeah animals celebrating um okay mops
thought here that's where I got captain
Chavez over here
ooh that's a good weapon spiked okay hey
Chad I should use less Oh pop yeah what
the [ __ ] was that holy [ __ ] did anyone
see that Ellie where are you Ellie what
the [ __ ] was that Daleks step on a bomb
or something like holy [ __ ] no I gotta
rewatch it do what the [ __ ] that was Oh
their trip wires [ __ ] [ __ ]
I work and all over there I get
something the wrong area that how that's
[ __ ] insane Haley I [ __ ] tripped a
wire me where health did [ __ ] a
although I got idler at the liver he'll
like this is [ __ ] up I don't think
it's gonna be way stuck in one less you
just gave me one that rigged can't tell
no I can't be ah there we go I gotta be
a mix [ __ ] right No okay hold on hey
says
how can you respond to what I did okay
okay okay in here ooh you shipping a
[ __ ] long time hey Nick but are these
families hey guys that Bond's take on an
ice bath lies i might as well just
[ __ ] make this shot
okay I can't [ __ ] rat is long we
don't ship anymore [ __ ] liars I'll be
good [ __ ] is going on here all right
okay yeah okay what's like the plan I'm
actually still confused on the west all
right not like in Pittsburgh am I just I
got up it's right now like trying it at
cities we're almost there that's the
ranch okay know what's gonna happen now
I stated a place like this back in the
Boston koozie oh [ __ ] you catch in here
Oh another one where [ __ ] out up there
posters are everywhere oh I saw ya Dona
the wolf part two I saw this not before
the outbreak you did did he totally
gutter by the end nobody gets gutted
it's a dump teen movie
I don't know does he stay focused all
right all right no I do not like the
side of this let's go through the alley
Oh [ __ ] truck that's all right just
keep your head down there where boys yup
chat he's on a blob yep at all them
thing is still there but
oh yeah as a guy in there
that's why now that music step lang I
know that
dick going in its going to circular
about it
holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
chef [ __ ] a holy [ __ ] and chat we
should probably get in LA
get this Isah
I supposed to destroy the truck I don't
know if I'm ready for that
Oh a chef now Ellie I'm going this way
okay spider central quack no one
hey lost undead
hurry i'm trying to [ __ ] hurry okay I
don't see anything you're lucky i mean
like another one go over their pocket ok
ok I'll do this this is how much it's
gonna show up
we're okay they can't see us look family
Oh leave him alone Oh easy son just take
it easy it's all right they're not the
bad guys lower the gun shut oh man you
hit hard and I was trying to kill you oh
yeah I thought you were one of them too
and I saw you they've got show Atlanta
if you haven't noticed they don't keep
kids around survival the fitness oh
you're bleeding is nothing yeah I could
if I can stop them I'm Henry Sam I think
I caught your name was Joel Ellie how
many are with you there all day hey we
don't know that nice shot we're a bunch
of us someone had the brilliant idea of
any on the city looked for supplies
those [ __ ] ambushed us scattered us
now it's all about getting out of this
[ __ ] okay okay we can help each
other le safety in numbers and all that
she's right he could help each other we
gotta hide I'll not too far from here be
safer if we chat there all right take us
there follow me
sorry about the whole shut the [ __ ] up
[ __ ] I would have probably done the
same if we if that could do now the gun
I'm gonna kill the away from Harvard me
to get a conversation no check out loud
toys in here anything on the mirror now
game oh is that yet mouth tough [ __ ]
yeah Altos like what's getting me
through this game [ __ ] [ __ ] like Jesus
okay can I can I think good here we got
to be careful we're right next to one of
their lookout areas okay it's just you
and your dog I promised someone I'd look
at ya I can appreciate that he's like
door look funny all right I'll a [ __ ] a
lot of [ __ ] got [ __ ] in here I'll
take tests out like that I was like this
out I guess I'll take that I'll take
tests I'll take this not a good [ __ ]
here that's just a nice TV I'll let me
get here holy [ __ ]
right here quick take this after Alec
dance I on that God get get that chef
who are your magazine early found out
her one of them comics highlight what is
that I can't use my shift I can broken I
lon con kids let's get kind of slow
sorry sir their kids got a slope behind
us now I'm a searcher okay I'm a
searcher holy [ __ ] wait wait everyone be
quiet get down get away from the windows
they're going man that [ __ ] truck
it's been hounding us episode honest
Dave Sam what are you doing nothing get
rid of it my backpack is practically
empty what's the word i'll take your
stuff it was enough to rule what is it
we only take what we have to that's
right now come on [ __ ] sad Helen only
take her magazines how far is this place
we're close real close recent to theseus
job at somewhere I thought he just
dropped it I should take a gear daylight
every [ __ ] up what the Fox are you think
what you find Ellie you watch her back
was up to see their long stay with her
somewhere the others they wanted to give
it another once over didn't miss
anything all right when I out over there
I'll check this area I'll look around
over here check down there come on come
on no
take aimer that pyromania i did it say
call a mastermind up on this truck hi
Chris big Chris feel like I'm crispy
like a hold on you have to love me let
me look around roll crack like an
episode of Atlanta shut yeah definitely
afraid betch you think I'm afraid [ __ ] I
won't shut around a second you sure it's
safe being so close to there where'd you
get that everybody through well thought
that I gotta check to c then it gets
[ __ ] here Oh me 14 how are you the same
what is that 14 home have university all
right how they were sick good stuff tell
me there's nothing that's helped [ __ ]
artist trial now I eat a public champion
it oh thank [ __ ] is an okay here's the
stuff in the kitchen area
oh my stuff in the kitchen area here we
are the alley like Angry dicks out for
her Rob